the best place to put your money when
World War III breaks out is going to be
Bitcoin now I know a lot of people
disagree people think that the best
place to put your money is gold is Cash
Bitcoin has actually proven itself
during hard times Bitcoin crashed to
$44,000 we had the big flu we had forced
lockdowns we had forced injections we
had supply chain issues we then had
riots Wars with Russia and Ukraine we
had BLM we had climate change the whole
world went crazy Bitcoin was still able
to go from $4,000 see out an entire
higher bull market highs of just under
$70,000 it's truly incredible I think
Bitcoin is proven itself through time